eh bien le métro est entré aujourd'hui
dans l'histoire de marseille un métro
que tous les marseillais en grand nombre
sont venus admirer ils ont été 100
milles à 150 milles environ à venir
donne dans l'après midi jusqu'à
maintenant bien entendu le métro est
ouvert jusqu'à minuit
ils ont donc admirer les stations haute
en couleurs l'esthétique de ce métro
orange et blanc le confort car il est
très confortable et également si j'ose
dire le silence car c'est vrai ce métro
est pratiquement silencieux ce matin à
9h30 il y a eu l'inauguration officielle
alors pas de ministres eux pas de
musique pour cette inauguration
proprement dite il y a eu par contre une
bonhomie très marseillaise et on santé
ici on respirer l'air frais la lavande
les parfums propre à la provence qui
contrastait avec l'air vif qui soufflait
dehors
le métro de marseille c'est la fête
surtout le jour de l'inauguration avec
le mistral glacée qui souffle à la
station la rose il faut bien cela pour
réchauffer les 15 cents invités du
premier voyage
gaston defferre arrive en compagnie de
lucien rochelle le préfet de région
même s'il en est maire de marseille on
ne peut éviter le ticket et après la
bouderie du premier portillons
automatiques devoir choisir le second
avec arthur notebart le président de la
communauté urbaine de lille qui sera la
troisième métropole française à être
équipée d'un métro avec henry bouchet le
directeur général du métro de marseille
c'est l'arrivée sur le quai pour le
premier voyage
messieurs 80 en direction de la station
c'est charles à la station 5 1 2 nuls au
chaud toutefois on pourrait pendant une
dizaine de minutes visiter la station
merci messieurs mais on a longtemps
parlé vrai que ce rêve devienne une
réalité que ressentons on est heureux on
a de la peine à y croire et je veux dire
qu'après avoir visité les chantiers vous
aurez étudie les dossiers
après avoir fait des marches sur des
marches
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est
l'accomplissement ce métro est très très
beau esthétiquement il est très
confortable il ne fait pratiquement pas
de bruit est-ce que vous ne redoutez pas
que les marseillais labit même type et
je courrai que que les marseillais
seront très attentifs et éviteront
d'abîmer le métro j'ai d'autres
expériences dans ce domaine par exemple
ce qui concerne les maisons de jeunes et
de la culture
nous avons confié aux mouvements de
jeunesse maison d'hôtes est
admirablement entretenu par les jeunes
que je rêvasse et sont fiers de la métro
et éviteront dhabi mais aucun ministre
n'est invité à l'inauguration bien ce
sont deux fleurs explique pourquoi
si j'avais invité à membres du
gouvernement j'aurais été moralement
obligé de tenir des propos assez
désagréable et comme je ne voulais pas
le faire
je n'ai pas invité deux membres du
gouvernement mais le gouvernement est
représentée ici dans son ensemble par
monsieur le préfet pour lequel j'ai
beaucoup d'égards et de considération et
par conséquent le gouvernement est
représentée ici de la meilleure façon
à la station en cinquième du longchamp
arrêt toujours la musique toujours la
fête
et toujours cette aimable désordre qui
ne nous a pas quittés depuis la rose et
qui ne nous lâchera plus ce n'est pas
encore le métro japonais et ses
pousseurs en gants blancs et nous nous
sommes pas loin
enfin après 18 minutes de voyage la
station saint charles
le terminus
bien sûr la conjoncture
eh bien j'espère que dans l'avenir tous
les jours à toutes les heures il ya
entendement de métro qu'aujourd'hui et
que tous ceux qui sont aussi contents
que je peux l'être
c'est ensuite à la gare arrestation
saint charles les discours d' usage
bilan remerciement est aussi mise au
point et puis j'ai dit ce que le métro a
coûté il aurait coûté moins cher si nous
n'avions pas dû payer les rails un prix
anormalement élevé nous sommes heurtés à
une coalition de fournisseurs nous avons
alors saisir et l'instance qualifié au
ministère des finances
nous attendons toujours la réponse
monsieur va faire son pain du boulanger
pâtissier au croissant aux petits pains
au chocolat ou sidérurgistes qui
pourtant au soir des prêts très
important de l'état elles s'étaient rêve
que vous n'avez pas encore tout à fait
réalisé alors qu'il est votre impression
en sortant de ce métro qui n'est pas le
vôtre c'est un rêve qui est pas terminée
mais c'est un rêve qui est engagée car
le matériel roulant et maintenant 60 %
réalisés le garage est également en
cours de chantier les trois premiers
lots sont partis
il me reste tout simplement qu'à tirer
des leçons ce que j'ai vu à marseille
mais trop élégant moderne
j'aime autant dire que j'étais frappé
d'élégance du viaduc j'ai constaté que
les nuisances n'étaient pas des choses
insupportables et j'espère que dans ma
région entière raconte
voilà c'était donc les grands moments de
cette journée d'inauguration du métro de
marseille retour à la station saint
charles